Speaker 1: There is a chilling dystopian
proposal from Florida Governor Ron DeSantis,
wherein bloggers who write about DeSantis or
Florida legislators would have to register
with the state. You've got a blog. You
write about Desanctis sometimes. Well,
we need to put you on a list. And the ACLU is
already saying this is unconstitutional. Newt
Gingrich is even saying that this is a bad idea.
So let's discuss. NBC News reports. Florida bill
would require bloggers who write about the
governor and legislators to register with
the state. The bill proposed by Republican State
Senator Jason Brodeur, would also require bloggers
who write about state officials to disclose who
is paying them and how much. Hmm. Interesting.
The bill is called information dissemination. If
a blogger posts to a blog about an elected state
officer and receives her will receive compensation
for that post, the blogger must register with the
appropriate office within five days of the post.
What it defines elected state officer is the
governor, lieutenant governor, Cabinet officer,
or any member of the legislature. If you failed to
register, you would get a fine of $25 a day. The
penalty would be capped at 20 $500 per post. The
bill says the bloggers reports to the state must
include the individual or entity that compensated
the blogger for the blog post and the amount
of compensation received from the individual
or entity. Of course, this could very quickly
be expanded to include independent journalists,
YouTubers and others. The bill defines a blog
quote as a website or web page that hosts any
blogger and is frequently updated with opinion,
commentary or business content. But it says the
term does not include the website of a newspaper
or similar publication. Desantis's office said it
was reviewing the bill as usual, that a governor
will consider the merits of a final bill if and
when it passes the legislature. This is really
scary stuff. Many of these posts also, or many
of these blogs are funded by advertising. And
it's not that someone says, Hey, I'll pay you 500
bucks to write the post. It's you write the post
and then it starts generating ad revenue, some
amount of ad revenue. The other question is about
platforms like Substack. Substack allows bloggers
to be compensated directly by their audience.
Often they are paid some number of dollars
a month. So the compensation proposed sort of
depends on the average number of paid subscribers
you have over the period that that post is live.
Very difficult. Aside from the chilling effect
that it has, generally very difficult sometimes to
determine the exact dollar amount associated with
this. The ACLU reports Business Insider believes
that this is a violation of the First Amendment
if passed, writes Business Insider. SB 1316 would
require all bloggers writing about DeSantis to
register with the state. Two organizations
told Insider This is a violation of the First
Amendment. The bill is un-American to its core. A
representative for ACLU Florida chapter said This
is a clear violation of the First Amendment
because it strongly discourages bloggers from
speaking on politics. One of the most critical
types of speech for maintaining a democracy, says
the ACLU rep. The ACLU rep added that the First
Amendment, quote, protects our right to learn
and read free from viewpoint based censorship. The
US Constitution demands we transcend such callous
political agendas and instead promote the value
of freedom of expression. While there's no doubt
that this is not a bill that promotes
speech. You can make the case it won't
limit it. It only enforces disclosure and
registration. But of course, in practice,
it absolutely will have that dampening effect on
those who would like to write about Ron DeSantis
in the state legislature. Newt Gingrich actually
tweeted about this. And on this particular point,
Newt Gingrich is correct. Former Speaker
of the House Newt Gingrich tweeting, quote,
The idea that bloggers criticizing a politician
should register with the government is insane. It
is an embarrassment that it is a Republican state
legislator in Florida who introduced a bill to
that effect. He should withdraw it immediately.
Now, the irony there. It's kind of a sad irony,
is that while Newt Gingrich is absolutely correct,
Newt Gingrich is also partially responsible for
creating the world in which something like this is
something Republicans are even willing to do. Now,
I'm not blaming him for the bill, but you can't
ignore the pivotal inflection point that happened
in the United States with the Republican Party
when Newt Gingrich became the speaker of the House
in 1994. And I've said more about that previously
on the show. If it's interesting to you,
check out my interview with Noam Chomsky, where we
discuss it. Let's hope it fails. But if it passes,
I'm wondering, might this force. The last
true liberal Dave Rubin out of the state of
Florida. Something to think about. We'll take
a quick break and be back right after this.